hello readers today we're going to be
talking about how smaller sections of
text work together to support the whole
text but first let us consider Voltron
it is a giant robot made up of five
smaller robots each one piloted by a
person five friends each with control
over a different part of the robot's
body you're up in the head I'm operating
the right leg our buddies operating the
left and so on in order to walk or pick
up objects or fight space monsters the
size of battleships all the disparate
parts of the robot have to function
together Wow texts work much the same
way each portion of the text from the
section level down to more granular
divisions like individual paragraphs or
sentences is trying to serve the broader
point of the text when we look at
Voltron foot in motion we analyze what
the foot is doing in the service of
Voltron as a whole if Voltron foot kicks
a ball we have to zoom out to ask is
Voltron playing soccer this is a pretty
abstract idea without any text examples
so let's stop talking about space robots
and start talking about the armor of
10th century Japanese horse archers
alright so this whole passage is about
the armor worn by mounted archer samurai
of 10th century Japan oh you're oi and
how its constructed so this is a piece
of armor this is the whole assemblage
and that's how the the piece is divided
right we've got these sections here for
each component the Kuras the O so day or
shoulder guards pakusa suti or armored
skirt and the Kabat or the helmet and
each one of these elements of the armor
connects back to the whole point of the
piece which is describing how the armor
does two things one it protects the
wearer and two allows them to ride
horses and fire arrows now we see this
in the introductory paragraph their
armor called oh yo I was designed
specifically to withstand the demands of
mounted archer warfare so let's dig into
this first section about the Kuras the
the the breastplate and backplate armor
I'll read the first paragraph Acuras is
usually a piece of armor that consists
of a breast
plate and a back plate that are attached
together the Kuras for the oue was a bit
different than a typical Kuras as it was
designed to be more effective for an
archer the Oh euro Icarus had three
sections instead of two a section to
protect the back a section to protect
the chest and a section to protect the
left side body the right side was left
open so the warrior could best utilize
his bow and arrow
so this paragraph is describing what a
Kuras is and how it functions as armor
but then it goes into detailing how and
oh yo to Akira's is different because
it's for someone holding a bow right it
has three sections instead of to the
right side was left open so the warrior
could best utilize his bow and arrow
this information down to this sentence
level all serves the same purpose it
serves to answer the question how was or
your armor specifically designed to meet
the needs of a mounted archer not every
sentence or every paragraph will address
every part of that main question note
that the Kuras section doesn't cover
anything about how the archers are on
horseback to answer that question we
need to go down to the third section the
gooses oudy the battle skirt I'm not
gonna read the whole paragraph let's
just zoom in on this one sentence the
Kusa zooty were designed so that when
the warrior was sitting in his horse's
saddle they fit nicely over the saddle
in a skirt like fashion to protect his
lower body and upper legs this
particular sentence tells us how this
part of the armor protects a samurais
legs while they're on horseback the
paragraph and section it's part of
detailed the whole construction of that
part of the armor and how it relates to
the other pieces and all of those
paragraphs together form one text that
explained the thing it's set out to
explain what is or yodel and how does it
work for 10th century Horse Archer
Samurai each section or paragraph is
like a leg or an arm of Voltron each
sentence is a muscle or a finger or a
robo toe together moving as one they
tell a story or make an argument which
is I guess like Voltron winning a fight
maybe if you like I've carried this
metaphor as far as it'll go
the point is if you're having trouble
making sense of an informational text
think of it as a giant battle
robot what is each component part of the
text trying to accomplish and when you
put all those parts together what are
they trying to do well my work here is
done you can learn anything Dave it out